day in the life
well i did say i would do this tonight
i can't believe my coding channel has
hit 5k subs thanks guys
i really appreciate it so you're going
to get some raw material
yeah i actually did just wake up and
thought for a minute
i was just having the craziest dream i
have i tend to have really vivid dreams
wow i did not want to wake up that was
it was amazing
sometimes my dreams are really scary and
nightmarish but this one was not this
one was
epic tom petty was there
we were in some bar something joe rogan
was
hosting it was weird man there's a bunch
of other people there
and there was this moment where i was
i was playing tom petty's guitar and
the bridge broke or messed up and we
were trying to fix it
and tom petty got frustrated and walked
away so uh
i was being fed alcoholic drinks all
right let me get to the rest of this
i could go on this was an amazing dream
i have awesome dreams all the time and i
love it
so i end up sleeping a lot sometimes or
sleeping in a lot just because
they're going on and i don't want them
to stop
you might think that i would have
cleaned before all this or something but
yeah stay hydrated have some kind of had
the sinus
extreme sinus these last few days it's
been pretty obnoxious
it's not really fun so i'm going to
drink a lot of water and
take a couple extra walks or something
today i guess and
hopefully it gets better all right this
is the computer room i have this mic
stand i was gonna use for some of this
recording
but i can't find the rest of my little
modules
so uh i might just be holding the phone
all day here's the system
the setup before turning it on so let's
go do that let's go experience
the power off
listen to that puppy roar and three
times a day i have to put in
these eye drops
all right well that's all done i was
just thinking about that dream a little
more
and there was something that was
happening earlier that was
like so it wasn't like all about famous
people or something as you might
uh imagine by the start of it it
actually had a bunch of my family in it
i can't remember exactly how it started
but there was some point in it where
there was this old gazebo
on the edge of an old town
uh they were like in the middle of an
old town in a little building and for
some reason
we bought it and we were fixing it up
and my
dad pulled up in his truck and was like
ready to cut some brush and trees and
my sister was there and my brother was
there and we all took this like family
photo like we used to when we were kids
and it was uh it was kind of
heartbreaking because well my dad passed
away and
my sister disappeared that's not a tear
that's from the eye drops
i guess enough about that there's a
little more to it but
ah dreams are weird it was actually a
good dream it was nice it was cathartic
in a way so i guess
now at this point i'm just gonna make
some coffee and see what i'm gonna work
on for the day
customary for every vlog to have a
moment where we brew coffee
we show it close up with the slow-mo or
something check out this cup man
i love this cup all right real talk i'm
proud of my mugs this one's from
this one's from an ex-girlfriend this
one i found i don't know where i found
this
look these mugs are amazing
this one my son got for me i love it
this one i just couldn't bear to get rid
of because i don't know it's
it's it's like etched with las vegas
i've never been to las vegas
it's the giant mug of tea and what else
we got
that's my son's this one just has a leaf
in it that's cool
these were uh kind of for my daughter
she picked this one out i think
i'll check it out on the inside it says
hello gorgeous
so uh occasionally if i use that one i'm
always like reminded of her
i don't know if this is gonna be
interesting but i'm just talking real
with you
yeah that's right i got corn dogs in my
cabinet
but it's not actually corn dogs it's
coffee pods
don't question it also i have all these
uh
cool plates and now i think we're just
gonna go sit down
or stand up rather into the computer
room
this is the computer room usually my
son's sitting there but he's at his
grandparents for the day
there's most of my magic collection old
mcdonald's
yeah i really should have cleaned before
recording but i will say those three
mcchickens were delicious
absolutely delicious i think the main
plan for today is we're going to do
a little bit of work on bullet physics
because someone requested that and i
need to know it anyway
so and i thought about streaming today
because i don't really have a whole lot
else to do
and if i'm being honest like streaming's
kind of fun sometimes
but for the most part it's actually
there's always like one or two people
per day that just kind of trigger me a
little bit
and make me question a lot of things
like
why am i even doing this like for
instance the last
uh or time before i go i streamed
someone like uh came in and was just
like hey
what about this language will you do a
tutorial on this
technology you've never used and just
kind of went on and on with stuff and
then i was like
i was just like no what do you what
what are you talking about why would you
come into a
c-plus plus dev's stream and ask them to
do tutorials on other languages
aren't there other streamers that use
other languages that you should ask this
question to
i guess they're desperate i don't i
don't know which is a weird place
maybe i should just get a hot tub and
call it a day because you know that
would actually probably make me a whole
whole lot more money than doing this
youtube coding channel and and coding
streams
just like bs and you know in a hot tub
apparently that's a thing i don't know
if i've got the figure for it though
kind of a little lacking in this chest
area
i've got a lot of monitors that i don't
need
like computers i don't need i i need to
post them
somewhere locally and get rid of them
but this is like a that's like a two
year ago thing
so they're just kind of sitting here at
this point uh cap size
one of my favorite cards ever yeah
there's there's a lot of little things i
should do like i'm supposed to ship out
some of these boxes to
other members of my family it's just
like some of my dad's
stuff that's still sitting here yeah
most of this is like pictures
and tons of documents and writings and
stuff from him some of it's kind of
interesting because he was a bit crazy
and
who knows what i'll find in them but
also they're really tedious to go
through
and uh that's full of belt buckles that
i probably need to sell
uh there's an old photo of us rafting oh
man
there's an old photo of like i guess
when he
his grandparents or something i don't
even know and i have no idea who this
dude is but apparently i'm related to
him
and also here we have a basketball that
my son and i found in the woods
don't ask questions okay all right we're
kind of in my living room now this is a
table that uh
if i have friends over we often just
play magic it just folds up
so it's not always in the middle of my
living room but it's here now
and that computer is for like recording
games and other
editing and stuff but i'm probably going
to sell it because
i'm a little broke right now all right
there's all my magic decks usually
they're over on that shelf in the other
room but right now they're just chilling
here
and oh oh what's that crazy guy in the
corner
oh man whoa what have we got going on
looks like a decently nice day out it's
not exactly sunny it's kind of dreary
but
that's fine with me maybe that's why my
head pressure's high
yeah can we talk about this work of art
this is uh my friend did that
that's that's not part of the art but um
yeah i thought it was kind of funny so i
just left it
so yeah actually my sister made that
like 20 years ago when she was in high
school or something
and uh well she's kind of gone now
not like totally gone she just like ran
away or disappeared and
won't talk to anybody because i i don't
know why she never really explained or
said why she just kind of did it
also she went a little crazy too so we
have questions about her
mental state anyway um i thought about
like
trying to auction this thing maybe and
and like sending her the money
because she probably needs it but i
don't think it will go for much
maybe if i put like uh it goes towards
mental health charity it'll go for more
i don't know
but i don't know what to do with this
thing it's just sitting here
i've kind of inherited it at this point
i can't just get rid of it because of
the
sentimental value yeah i don't think my
family would be too happy with me if
they found
out that i threw out the wireframe guy
someone would take it before it got
thrown out i'm sure
also i'm uh considering rewriting my
game engine
but this time i'm i think it's time to
drop opengl support i haven't completely
figured out opengl but i've learned a
lot from it
and i've been researching vulcan and i
think i might go into pure vulcan
because it seems to run on everything
and i think you can optimize it just as
well as directx but yeah i have a game i
really want to make
and i don't really want to use another
engine so i think it's time and i'm
going to drop
the ancient so it's just going to be
archer engine which i think makes more
sense i just got to figure out the
namespace
saying namespace used to be aaa what's
it going to be now it's not ancient
archer
yeah i kind of have a lot of magic cards
this isn't even the start of it
maybe i'm a hoarder but the reality is
when i started playing i have a lot of
old friends that play so tons of them
gave me their boxes of bulk and commons
this is only the start of it this is
nothing so i guess if you guys ever see
this thank you ryan
chris sean for all the bulk cards i
appreciate it
helped me get into the game a lot
actually
you know who you are all right someone
wanted to see my bookshelf so here it is
um well this tube thing has actually got
dnd maps and a dnd
battle map in the map of baron that's
pretty old i've had that forever
um but yeah this is my book show i don't
actually
read or use it a whole lot anymore
because i know this is crazy but
we've got the internet but uh yeah i've
got some dnd books down here a few of my
college books
some books that i just thought would be
interesting because i heard about them
this my my late grandfather got me
because he thought i'd like it
economics apparently it's really good
and just a few other programming books
linux administration
and a few more college books and stuff
and uh i don't know nothing too
fancy and i've got just some
fantasy books here and a bunch of the
viking books
from way back in the day like uh tolkien
this is beowulf a lot of the viking ones
are actually really good and they're
kind of short too so it's nice
so highly recommended if you like that
kind of stuff
but yeah apparently tolkien studied that
stuff a lot and also i've got these
weird uh
what does the bible really teach books
this is kind of got
a friend of mine gave this to me and
it just like starting to read it made me
laugh so much
that i had to keep it well i don't know
if i want to get into it but basically
it's it's just really easy to tear this
apart and just kind of show how
foolish it is to believe this stuff
blindly
oh wow but i've also got a book
from or a little poetry book that a
friend of mine wrote
and i do have the bible believe it or
not i actually do read it sometimes no
i'm not a christian or anything
but i find some of the stories to be
interesting and to like read it for
myself is kind of interesting like
recently
i've read parts of the book of job
and it kind of teaches you about
perseverance and not giving up when
things get difficult
which is actually a really important
lesson nothing to do with god so
there's actually good stuff like that in
the bible even if you're not religious
and i've got some elminster
[Music]
uh books he's like my favorite character
uh yeah i just happened upon this book
when i was a kid the kingless land and i
absolutely
loved it this book is amazing and ed
greenwood is kind of a legend he's uh
he's the wizard from forgotten realms
he's uh helminster basically
anyway this book has its character in it
named shadovar and that was my world of
warcraft name
for a long time as a lot of people might
know
probably not anyone that watches this
channel anymore hey look a chemistry
book that i bought in leaflets because
it was cheaper that way
yeah this is kind of another little this
is like my business area over here it's
basically where i do
uh shipping and stuff of things i sell
and just like
paperwork i have to handle all my
mailing materials
over here and hey look a ds that never
yes whatever call it ideas a switch that
never gets played because my son plays
roblox instead glad we spent 300
on it uh
so yeah aside from mail that i probably
need to
cut out of this video because it has
personal information i tend to like list
magic cards pretty often and uh other
things
just to make extra money because i don't
exactly have a day job right now in case
you haven't figured that out
and it's not that i have anything
against day jobs
i worked them a lot in the past so i
actually have quite a bit
saved up but uh i don't know
it's getting a little risky at this
point using my savings a lot of times i
i don't quite make enough from all the
things i do but it's been slowly
increasing so
maybe another year or two i'll make
enough to pay all my bills uh until then
i'm just gonna have to figure things out
i probably will have to get a job i
considered actually looking for a job
today
the thing is in the area i'm in a small
town
so there's not a whole lot of
programming jobs so it's mostly stuff
online that i
try to do and just dealing with
finding a job is not exactly fun i tend
to be a little too brutally honest
sometimes which some people like
and to other people it scares them
so yeah at this point i think i'm just
gonna start working on some code and
stuff like i was talking about earlier
um it's actually still pretty early in
the morning i just decided to like walk
around and talk about things because
while i got your attention so yeah
it's it's real it's tuesday it's july
22nd
7 54 am and i'm i'm pretty much ready to
go
usually i work out or something too so
i'll probably do it at some point my
mother always said
coden you gotta light the code candle so
we're gonna go do that real quick
looks like my startup script is doing
great oh yeah i should also mention that
i might
do some research on networking libraries
because when i rewrite my game engine i
need to get networking
in there the game i want to make does
require a server
it's top secret i'm not going to tell
you what the game is if i just told you
about it you'd make it
it'll be ruined collaboration of ideas i
just think it'd be really fun and it's
something i really love to play
so as far as i can tell it's never going
to happen unless i make it because i
don't think this
this particular flow of a game
is on anyone's radar so i'm pretty
excited to do it
i just don't know how i'm going to do it
there's so much technology i need to
learn
so much i need to add to my engine no i
won't learn unreal or unity stop telling
me to
well okay i guess it's not that i won't
learn them it's that
i want to know how they're made
i i'd rather build the technology to use
someone else's ghetto
broken tools like uh look at icarus
watch a big fry's channel look at all
these terrible games made with unreal
and unity nobody can actually make
proper games with those engines they're
all broken they're all full of bugs
and it's because well it's like that 30
million line problem
or the no code movement you don't know
what you're actually getting you're just
slapping stuff together and hoping for
the best i don't want to do that i
actually want it to work properly so
that's why i want to build my own engine
yeah that's my boom mic stand it's
pretty awesome isn't it
and also this is the most expensive
monitor stand to have
a hundred dollar algorithms book i have
decided to stream for the day
please don't make me regret this twitch
well just got done streaming
it's it was a pretty long one just a lot
of lot of coding
but it was super successful got some
network
locally tested and initialized for the
first time
and uh got some vulcan initialized so
kind of set up to start ancient archer
with a new version
uh yeah we're getting rid of opengl and
we're going to move to vulcan
i also did some testing of like bullet
physics and stuff a bunch of stuff on
stream
it's a lot of fun consider tuning in if
you want to see some live coding or
interact with me live i'm going to co or
i'm going to
stream as often as i can but it's also
uh
really nice outside so i got to get out
there i've just been uh
not getting any sun yet so we're gonna
go get some sun
the day in the life continues it's kind
of odd doing this video but
i'm enjoying it hope you guys are
enjoying it let me know what you think
is my life all that different from yours
or
do we have a lot in common i don't know
you tell me
actually i'm just trying to get you to
leave interactions let's let's be honest
all right all right let's be honest okay
and we're driving i'm just gonna go to
like a park into like a walk trail
for a bit and uh get some exercise
basically
i kind of gotta do this or i notice i
get in a funk
so i know uh some people rage about how
how dare you as a coding channel tell us
that you exercise
but i'm not callum upton i uh
i'm not that bitter okay yeah i guess
you know
it's been on my mind that i'm always
amazed at how like bitter and angry and
upset
some really popular youtubers are
because i always thought that it was
really hard to grow
if you were like that but i guess it's
not the case because like uh
my gaming channel you know i was pretty
raging on there a lot and i couldn't get
new subs and i thought that was why
but maybe it wasn't why because it seems
to work pretty
well for a lot of people i guess i'm
just not gonna worry about that stuff as
much as i can and i'm just trying to be
myself
at this point it's a it's really easy to
compare yourself to other people and get
depressed or
sad or whatever but it's really just not
helpful because you're not them
and they're not you so you just gotta
stay true to yourself
that's what i think anyway all right
well i was out
just decided to run some errands and get
some fresh food
i gotta start eating healthier so uh
yeah
fresh food is it i just
love this city okay well i did end up
going for much of a walk
because uh well the place i went to park
i noticed
you're not allowed to so i didn't want
to get towed and then i realized
well i'm out let's just run some errands
so i went to the pharmacy and picked up
my
eye drops that i that have been sitting
there for like five days
so and then i went shopping and now i
got food that he's doing in the fridge
so yeah i'm just gonna go back home but
anyways i was also thinking
you know sometimes people ask me stuff
like why don't you advertise your
discord more
why don't you try to get more people on
your discord and
i guess the reason is i don't really
want it to become a burden
i only made it because some people
requested to begin with
i'm not really interested in getting it
popular or getting all that popular
i kind of prefer to be the underdog or
the unknown diamond in the rough
i just feel like most famous people are
not that cool
and i don't even understand why people
like them to begin with so
i don't know it's it's not really
directly correlated with me necessarily
because i just feel like
well i guess the point i'm trying to get
to is i feel like a lot of people
get big or famous for like the wrong
reasons and i'd rather become
well known for actually uh
who i am and not because some other big
creator shouts me out or something
you know so i guess i just like natural
growth
it's about midday right now uh
feeling a little tired probably going to
take a nap do some reading do a little
research
and maybe design a little bit of how i
want my new engine to be
while i'm chilling there so we'll see
yeah
basically just gonna make some food
and uh yeah that's the plan chill
research relax about an hour or two
and then see what how i feel and what i
feel like have you ever
seen such delicious food
if this video gets 100 likes i will
write
you guys a song on this guitar
and i'll i'll post it
why is there dead wasp on my floor
well i just had like one of the most
epic naps ever that was
nice it's now like eight o'clock uh
sun is on the on the go down
i reinvigorated so i think i'm going to
get up and code some more in a few
minutes
i should probably work out first though
that's right
hold on to your ladies button up over
here
all right also this is the computer i'm
going to be using for
my test server for all my networking
stuff
yeah she served as well and also when my
ebay items sold so i got some shipping
to do
i printed the shipping labels which i'm
not going to show you because uh it has
addresses
and now i've got to find the card that
sold i think it was
this kranko guy a whopping 4 bucks
but hey it's still more than 90
of my videos making ad revenue so
consider being a patron if you want my
tutorials to keep being free forever
i just realized i think oh that's no
excuse
oh it's some kind of vertigo sinus
pressure
thing oh it kind of sucks it feels fine
now but as soon as i like
uh bend down or something it's like this
extreme
pressure in my head i should probably
see a doctor for that because who can't
really afford
insurance consider becoming a patron
today i don't mean to sound like an
e-beggar i realize how this sounds
but uh yeah the reality is
i've said it before for the most part
doing these videos isn't actually really
worth my time so i probably do have to
find a new business model
at some point i did say i was going to
keep it real and that is the truth
most my videos only make like 50 cents a
month or less
you know which is starting to add up
because i have a lot of videos at this
point and some of them are actually
doing pretty well i think there's like
i think there's three that do well
there's three that make like
more than a dollar a month that's not
very many out of the total
of videos i have huge shout out to my
diamond patron
nasser al haldi carrying the channel
absolutely carrying it nasser hit me up
if you
have any special request videos because
i probably owe you one at this point
maybe even two okay well
i'm firing up this computer and setting
up a remote session to it
um it's already port forwarded on this
thing
and should be pretty well uh ready for
connections i just gotta actually put a
server on it
and run it and accept connections so uh
yeah good server who needs pets when
you've got
computers you can see the dust coming
off of this thing
still less maintenance than a cat or a
dog but it will never cuddle with me and
if it does
it's a hard chunk of metal oh and i
totally found my little thing that i was
talking about way earlier
yeah it's attached to my webcam that's
where it's been the whole time
yeah yeah yeah that's a box of random
computer parts over there
yeah that's a tinfoil hat i got this
specifically for when i
watch alex jones on podcasts and stuff
he's gotta love doing research online
where you find
epic information like heavily
lightweight setting up the development
environment on the server here
and we're going to see if we can get
this server talking to my other computer
because if so
boom we're actually getting pretty close
to being able to
host our own game servers for our own
game and that sort of thing and i'll
make some tutorials so
look forward to that it's about nine
o'clock at night
it's usually about this time i start
gaming or something
and lately i've been feeling like
really depressed about gaming i don't i
don't know i can't fully explain it so
i actually left my gaming discord which
was
kind of stupid because it was a lot of
real life friends but
it's like when i have this feeling of
being kind of sad i can't
help but go on there and just like veg
out on a game that
doesn't make me happy and i have to
break the cycle so
i'm just kind of accepting the sadness
right now and
i can't even explain it but it feels
like it's
about this time that i try to like i
don't know maybe edit some of my profile
stuff either make it a little better
or remove the stuff i think is not good
and
i don't know it kind of feels like
self-sabotage but
it's the struggle of life i guess you
know kind of sad
not not a bad way not like you would
think it's just like
maybe it's like an unsatisfied feeling
or something
i don't know does that happen to anyone
else all right well i gotta end this
uh it's pretty much the end of the day
i'm just gonna work a little bit more
maybe watch some videos and
try to find something to be a little
happy about or something i don't know
and
uh i don't know maybe i'll call a friend
all right
well peace out guys thanks for watching
and thanks for getting me to 5 000 subs
that's
crazy so i'll do another one of these
type of things at six thousand see you
[Music]
later
[Music]
you